- I think with ADHD, the
problem is that you sort of...
- And I try to rephrase this
'cause I'm sort of going on a tangent.
- What just happened?
- What was I saying?
(bright music)
I misbehaved a lot as a kid,
but I didn't mean to.
- The natural environment of a classroom
is very non-conducive
to somebody with ADHD.
You know, just like this quiet room,
you're sitting at this table,
a bunch of other kids
are all doing their work.
It was almost like a sensory overload.
Like everything is coming
at you all at once.
- I would be trying to
focus on this teacher
and then all of a sudden,
I would snap to it again,
and I had missed half of what
the teacher had talked about.
It's like you're high or something, like,
it's like (laughs), it's kind
of similar to being high.
- One of the side-effects of ADHD
is a sort of inability,
or at least a tough time
staying still, concentrating,
focusing on day-to-day tasks.
- I feel like my thoughts
are sort of on like,
a carousel in my brain,
and it's going in circles,
and each thought stops
for like two seconds
in front of my eyes.
I can barely grasp it, and then it's gone.
- The third day I was at Buzzfeed,
I was taking some like,
safety test with my friend,
fellow producer here, Caitlin.
And I'm like already lost on the packet,
I look over and Caitlin's answered
the first 10 questions already.
And it's just that that's
like the story of my life,
is like, looking over to
my friend, and being like,
"How the hell did you just do that?"
- I have been on some form of medication
ever since I was 13.
- I stopped taking medication.
For me, because I just didn't
like the way it made me feel.
They curb my appetite,
I was losing weight.
- But the medication
provides me with clarity.
- When I'm not on my medicine,
it feels like the smallest
tasks are really overwhelming
because I can't visualize and focus
on the simple process.
- I have to plan things out,
I have to write everything
down or else I forget.
I don't advocate that
everyone go off their meds
if they don't need to, it's just for me,
that was something that
I felt I wanted to do.
- It looks different in everybody.
I would just wish people
were a little more sensitive
with the verbal assumptions they make.
- I just wish people believed it was real.
My ADHD is like the
realest thing in my life.
Like I can't reach out and touch it,
but I can feel it.
(bright music)